(band stops playing)
(audience cheering)
- Welcome back y'all.
Today we honor the legacy of
Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
I am here with Cedric the
Entertainer and Pam Grier,
give it up.
(audience cheering)
My next guest is the drummer
and front man for The Roots.
We love him. You can catch
him five nights a week
on The Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon.
Last year, he won an Oscar
(horn noises)
for his documentary
"Summer of Soul"
(audience cheering)
and this year, y'all,
he might do it again.
He is the executive
producer of "Descendant"
a new Netflix documentary
that traces the legacy
of the last slave ship to
land in the United States.
- [Narrator] What I know of
the story is that it came
down to a bet and Timothy Mayor
said, "Yeah we can do this".
And Captain William Foster,
he built "The Clotilda",
set sail in April of 1860
and went into Dahomey,
at the time, now, Benin,
captured these individuals,
came back into Mobile Bay and was able to
release these people, sell them to buyers,
and enslaved them.
Foster was able to take it
up the river and burn it.
What was left, eventually
sunk into the river.
(audience clapping)
- Dialing in from New York,
please welcome Ahmir
Questlove Thompson, everybody.
(audience cheering, band playing)
What's up, Questlove! Say
hi to Cedric, say hi to Pam.
- Hey, what up, dawg!
- Hey, what's up. How
you doing? Hello, Pam.
- So Questlove, this story was never told
in the history books.
I had never heard it,
watched the documentary.
I found it completely
interesting, appalling,
like, all the things.
There were so many words
to describe it, but it,
these are the stories. I
feel like there's so many
like this that have not been told.
How do you think this happens?
- Well, you know, there is,
there's a commonality in terms
of why, you know, education is important.
Like, we're currently living
in a time in which we're kind
of debating is like, you
know, is critical race theory
important to teach at the schools?
Like, this story is a prime
example of why that's important
because, you know, not only
did you know, but I was well
into my late 40's before
I knew,
and this is why acknowledging
history is important and why,
you know, erasure is real.
You know, we can't know as a world where
we're going unless we
know where we came from.
- So we don't repeat it.
Well, before the taping
we asked our audience
to watch the film. It's powerful, right?
(audience cheering)
Like, I watched it last night
and honestly there's, so I felt
like watching the documentary,
literally, there were like,
almost like, four documentaries in one.
Like, you could go off
on different aspects
of this and dive deeper,
'cause there's so many things happening
in this community and
just overall in society.
So this movie is personal to you, though
because you're not only a producer
but also a descendant, right?
- Well, it's personal to
me because back in 2017,
I was a guest on the PBS
show "Finding Your Roots",
with Skip Gates. And it was
there, for the first time
in my life, that I had heard of Benin,
that I heard the name
Charles and Maggie Lewis,
that I heard of an Africatown.
You know, 1% of African
Americans in this country
can name their,
their slave ship, can name the
country that they came from.
Like 99% of us don't know what
part of Africa we came from.
That's like one of the largest
continents in the world.
So, you know, that makes
you feel complete inside.
Like I did the show and suddenly, I came
from not knowing I had
a history to knowing
that I'm literally somebody.
Like, I know where I came from.
So when the story of this film came up,
I just wanted to be a
part of it just so that
I can have life completion and
on knowing who my family is.
But yeah,
if any way that I can a elevate
or bring forth this story,
amplify it, I'm with
it. Absolutely with it.
- Yeah.
So, Questlove's band-mate
Black Thought is also
an executive producer on the
film, and the movie was picked
up by Barack and Michelle
Obama's production company.
So Questlove, why do you
think these stories are so
important to share?
- You know, I think for me personally,
again,
it's a feeling of
completion. You know, again,
like, I have friends who
know that they're Italian.
I have friends that know
that they're from France or
Switzerland or, you know,
and not many black people
in the United States could say, like,
"Oh, my family came from Ghana",
or, "My family came from", you know,
South Africa, or any other
part of the continent.
And as a result there might be a
a kind of nihilistic,
incompletion,
incomplete feeling that
we have as human beings.
I instantly know that the second I heard,
like, the name Benin and,
you know, where I came from,
instantly my whole
demeanor changed, you know,
and that's why I feel as
though this is important
because we now have the tools
to see where we came from.
- Yeah.
- So now's I think, now is the first time
in our lives in which we can
find out what our history is.
That's why it's important.
- Yeah. Connection is important.
I feel like, and also I
feel like these stories
are important too, because
it really does show you,
just slaps you in the face with imbalance.
Opportunity is not there for people.
Education to even help
their own community,
is not available to people.
Like, it's, it really does,
I think the documentary does a great job
of depicting imbalance
and how true that is.
People talk about it,
but it does a great job.
You visually see it happening
and you experience it with
the people of this town.
- The way my mother told me this,
that Timothy Mayer, a local businessman,
made a bet that after
slavery was abolished
that he could still bring
Africans into the country.
And he went and got a bunch
of Africans and brought us,
brought them back here to
the mouth of the Mobile River
just let 'em off the boat
and burned the ship to conceal the crime.
- Welcome back on this
Martin Luther King Jr. Day.
I'm here with Cedric the
Entertainer and Pam Grier.
(audience cheering)
That was a clip from the
new Netflix documentary,
"Descendant", which
chronicles 'The Clotilda',
the last slave ship to come to America.
It also documents modern day
Africatown, in Mobile, Alabama.
Residents there are said
to be the descendants
of that ship and that
legacy was proven true when
they found 'The Clotilda' in 2019.
It's executive-produced by
Ahmir Questlove Thompson
and he's on the line
with us from New York.
It also features my next
guest. Like Questlove,
she's a direct descendant
from The Clotilda
and she still lives in
the area to this day.
Please welcome Veda Tunstall, y'all.
(audience cheering)
- Hello.
I literally am, no B.S.,
I connected with you so much in the film.
I feel like we have
similar thoughts and when
you're talking about things on, you know,
justice and "how do you
fix it, where do you go?"
And, and even leaving things
open to like, we need help.
Like, there's, what do you do?
Like, ideas, and I felt
like I connected with you
so much on that.
So, "Descendant" connects
the past to the present.
So, tell us about the
challenges facing your community
'cause like, even how it
leaves off the documentary,
like, what it leaves off
with like, it's kind of like,
open-ended like, things are
still trying to progress.
So what, where are you at right now?
- There are organizations
and people who've been
at work for all these years.
Like, it's not new that work
is being done in Africatown
but there's still a
lot of work to be done.
It's still true that the
community is surrounded
on all sides by heavy industry.
There's work being done to
mitigate the negative impact
of those,
those plants and all
the chemical, you know,
- The amount of people
with cancer is insane.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- And I was just talking to
a friend of mine a few days
ago who used to teach at
Mobile County Training School
and she said somebody needs
to do some research on this
because the number of children
with neurological disorders
and intellectual
disabilities, she was like,
it's gotta be because the
soil is toxic, the air
is toxic and the water is toxic.
So, today there's a lot
of work being done on the,
with Environmental Justice or I call it
"environmental injustice", that we are,
we were just in Washington
DC, speaking with people
from the EPA about resources
to help Africatown with that.
This community was self-sustaining
some years ago until
it was incorporated
into the city of Mobile.
So there were,
there were businesses,
there was healthcare
there was everything there,
but now it's not there, so...
- They addressed that in the documentary.
He was like, "I used to live here.
I used to live across the
street." Now it's all changed
- It's all gone.
- Yeah.
- So now that this film has come out
it's shined a light over the
whole world on Africatown.
So what we are hoping now
is that because everybody's
paying attention that we can do something
about these things.
We are already speaking with
the EPA and federal government,
local government, you know,
we are, we're having to work
with our local government
because they're not really
addressing the issues
like we need them to.
So we are still working on that.
We need access to healthcare.
There's no clinic in
Africatown, people have
transportation issues.
So, even though there are needs
in the community, there is a
it's a proud community.
People are working hard
to bring Africatown back
to the community that it
used to be, self-sustaining.
- Flourish, like it was. Yeah.
I think, that is also
what's so important about
and you know, thank you Quest. Thank you,
all these producers that
are, you're shining a light.
You're saying, "Well we've been doing this
for a minute," but see, nobody knew
like, this is important
that people shine a light.
People that have a spotlight
to take that spotlight
shine it where it needs to go.
And really, 'cause there are
so many people that watch that
go, "What can I do? What
can I do? How can I help?"
You know, there are people
watching that are like,
"Wait, I know I've worked with,
you know, the EPA on this.
Maybe I can help here at this".
People, I think I have to
believe always that there's hope
like that, that people want to help.
And I just think this
is what's so important
about films like this and
documentaries about this
is that this is real
life. This isn't a movie.
- Right. Right.
- This is, these are
people's lives, you know?
And to call it like what
it is, to say what it is,
you know, gentrification,
to say what it is.
These people are encroaching on it.
They want everybody to leave.
They wanna keep their
plants there, they don't
wanna change it.
That's 'cause it's greed
and power rule the world.
- Absolutely.
And you know, at the end
it's not, nothing's changed.
People need help. Like, people need that.
So that's why I'm so glad
that you're here talking to us
about it.
And I'm so glad that
people watching will get to
maybe have that impact.
Well, we reached out to
our friends at My Heritage,
which lets anyone easily
trace their family history
through their website, myheritage.com
They love the work The
Africatown Heritage Preservation
Foundation is doing for the community.
So they're gonna donate $10,000 to help
out 'cause they were touched by y'all.
(audience cheering)
As we mentioned, "Descendant" is released
through The Obama's production company.
Michelle Obama is encouraging everyone to
share their family history
through photos and stories.
Use the hashtag #descendantchallenge.